bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir la flambé de l'antisémitisme en
France bonsoir àiel Goldman bonsoir
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous vous
êtes avocat président du Fond Social
Juif Unifié on va revenir tout à l'heure
avec vous sur les chiffres sidérants
publié aujourd'hui par le CRIF
1676 actes antisémites en 2023 plus 1000
% depuis le 7 octobre et les massacres
du Hamas c'est bien simple tout augmente
les agressions physiques les menaces les
insultes et même le milieu scolaire
n'est plus épargné on en parle tout à
l'heure dans la deuxème partie notre
grand débat ce soir que reste-t-il de la
loi immigration on va se pencher dans le
détail sur les différentes censures du
Conseil constitutionnel les neuf sages
qui ont retoqué 35 articles sur 86 soit
un/ers du texte exite toutes les mesures
ajouté par la droite alors tout ça pour
ça qui gagne qui perd ce soir de la
majorité ou des oppositions après cette
décision notre débat avec mes invités
dans un tout petit instant sur ce
plateau enfin nosa franchi ce soir
l'économie Thomas Lestavel
l'international Isabelle lasser et puis
Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée avec Stéphanie des piierr
voilà pour le sommaire on y va Ariel
Goldman ça vous regarde top
générique
[Musique]
c'est donc une censure large et même
très large he qui restera sans doute
dans les annales du Conseil
constitutionnel les neuf sages ont
invalidé des pan entiers de la loi
immigration la plupart des mesure ajouté
par la droite ont été censuré on va s'y
arrêter avec cette question ce soir le
Parlement sort-il grandi après une telle
décision bonsoir Christopher Weissberg
merci d'être là vous êtes député
renaissance des Françis qui vivent aux
état atsunis et puis porte-parole du
groupe Renaissance à l'Assemblée je
précise d'entrée de jeu que vous avez
choisi de vous abstenir sur la loi
immigration c'est important dans dans ce
débat mais vous représentez votre groupe
qui l'a bien voté majoritairement
largement bonsoir Benjamin Lucas bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes député
écologiste des yelines bonsoir Benjamin
Morel merci d'être avec nous on a
évidemment besoin d'un
constitutionnaliste sur ce plateau ce
soir maître de conférence en droit
public à l'université Panthéon Assas et
puis les républicains bien sûr leur
réaction on a envie de les entendre à
distance ce soir avec nous Annelore Blin
bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes député
LR du menenloire alors qu'est-ce qu'elle
dit précisément cette décision censure
partielle ou totale sur la forme et sur
le fond c'est dans le récap de mon amie
et néanmoins collègue Elsa
monagava bonsoir Elsa vous revenez tout
juste de la rue de montpenscier là où
siègent les neuf sages du Conseil
constitutionnel et vous avez ausculé de
très près cette décision oui exactement
et regardez Myriam on a le numéro 1 on a
le numéro 3 on a le 65 le 45 le 33 le 13
je vous fais pas le tirage du l'ut au
soir non tout ça ce sont tous les
articles que le Conseil constitutionnel
a censuré 32 complètement 3IS
partiellement on le sait cette décision
elle était très attendue nous les
journalistes on été convoqué à 15h45
pour une décision à 16h30 tapante et
donc la coupe vous l'avez dit elle est
franche c'est 40 % de la loi qui est
tombée ce soir et c'est pas n'importe
quel parti souvenez-vous en décembre
dernier on en a parlé de ces mesures qui
ont fait polémique les restrictions au
regroupement familial le délai d'accès
aux prestations sociales ça pouvait être
jusqu'à 5 ans pour toucher les
allocations familiales pour un étranger
en situation régulière la fin de
l'automaticité du droit du solol la
caution étudiante le débat sur les
orientations plurriatelles de la
politique migratoire tout ça censuré
tout bonnement par le Conseil
constitutionnel alors comment se
justifie le Conseil est-ce que ça veut
dire que toutes ces mesures sont
inconstitutionnelles alors justement
myiam c'est plus subtile que ça
d'ailleurs ça a suscité de nombreuses
interrogations parmi les journalistes
présents 32 articles censurés ils ne
sont pas sur le fond ils le sont parce
que ce sont des cavaliers législatifs
cavalier ça n'a rien à voir avec le
cheval ça à voir avec la Constitution et
son article 45 selon lequel il faut un
impérativement avoir un lien même ind
direct avec le texte déposé ou transmis
alors vous me direz bah tous ces
articles ils avaient bien un lien avec
l'immigration oui mais ça c'est le titre
du texte il faut vraiment que chaque
mesure s'accroche à un article initial
pour bien comprendre ça ne veut pas dire
que toutes ces mesures elles seront
constamment jugées inconstitutionnel par
le Conseil constitutionnel non c'est
juste que là elles sont pas au bon
endroit dans le texte il y a seulement
deux articles censurés sur le fond dont
celui qui imposait à l'assemblée de
débattre sur des quôtas migratoires
alors comment on réagit ce soir du côté
du gouvernement et des oppositions alors
le ministre Gérald daranin a réagi très
vite sur Twitter avec une réaction qu'on
va décrypter un petit peu regardez loi
immigration Conseil constitutionnel
valide l'intégralité du texte du
Gouvernement le gouvernement prend acte
comme j'ai pu l'indiquer lors des débats
de la censure de nombreux articles mais
regardez ajoutz au Parlement mais oui le
ministre de l'Intérieur il a raison ce
sont les articles ajoutés par la droite
qui ont bien été censurés ce soir oui
mais la majorité elle les a bien voté
ces articles en commission mixte
paritaire puis en séance au
rassemblement national réaction assez
logique de Jordan bardellaa leur
président qui dénonce un coup de force
des juges à droite on s'estime tout
simplement trahi ériic cotil Conseil
constitutionnel a censuré la loi
immigration ils ont jugé en politique
plutôt qu'en droit et cette censure elle
été attendue par le Président de la
République on réclame une réforme de la
Constitution bah évidemment la droite
elle avait négocié
pour accepter finalement de voter le
texte et puis tout ce qu'elle avait
négocié est tombé ce soir d'où ces
tweets des républiquain merci beaucoup
Elsa mondingava Elsa qui va s'installer
à côté de Benjamin Lucas parce qu'elle
va être précieuse dans ce débat pour la
dimension décryptage politique je vais
commencer avec Benjamin Morel forcément
c'était très attendu 35 des 86 articles
censuré totalement ou partiellement il y
a les fameux cavaliers législatifs va
falloir revenir même si c'était très
clair coup de chapeau Elsa mais quand
même c'est c'est c'est particulier ça
veut dire que ils sont censurés
uniquement sur la forme mais il n'avait
pas de lien vraiment avec l'immigration
je comprends pas alors le lien en
réalité tel qu'il est conçu par le
Conseil consel en matière de cavaler
législatif est un lien qui tout de même
peut-être considéré comme étant très
direct même si la contion était réformée
en 2008 et qu'on parle de lien indirect
le Conseil constitutionnel exige que et
bien c'est ce soit directement dans la
ligne du texte et comme ça bien bien été
dit et bien que les dispositions
originelles du texte permettent et bien
de se rattacher à ces apports or si vous
regardez le texte originel par exemple
la question des allocations des appels
et cetera il y a rien auquel vous pouvez
vous raccrocher et donc c'est ce qu'on
appelle un cavalier et donc cette
jurisprudence là elle a pas été inventée
pour ce textelà elle est jurisprudence
constante depuis déjà très très
longtemps on essayie de l'infléchir en
2008 ça n'a pas vraiment marché donc là
il était tout de même très très
probableens pas vraiment qu'on a une
sensure sur le base des cavaliers mais
ça veut dire que quand le Conseil
examine un texte une disposition et juge
que c'est un cavalier il regarde pas au
fond donc ce qu'il l' a censuré sur la
il dégage si j'ose dire il inval je vais
pas travailler sur quelque chose sur
lequel je n'ai pas travaillé parce que
c'est un cavalier donc il met ça de côté
ça veut pas dire que les dispositions
qui ont été censurées comme cavalier
elles sont pas inconsuelles au fond qu'
y a pas de d'atteinte au principe
d'égalité et cetera on saura ça si
demain elle se retrouve dans un nouveau
texte et que le conseil à nou à se
prononcer mais alors ça c'est pour
l'interprétation juridique avec
lesquelle vous êtes on le sent d'accord
que vous suivez que vous comprenez mais
il y a là aussi la politique là ce soir
on se dit quand on connaît pas le le
détail des subtilités du Conseil
constitutionnel on se dit mais en fait
le Conseil constitutionnel il dit au
députés comment faire la
loi les députés le savaient est-ce que
est-ce que là on n'est pas dans une
forme de de jeu de dupe ce soir il y a
en grande partie un jeu de dupe
qu'est-ce qui va se passer qu'est-ce qui
se passe déjà vous avez montré les twe
notamment d'un certain nombre de leaders
de la droite et bien vous allez avoir
deux possibilités pour la droite de
rebondir c'est soit de dire bah écoutez
les dispositions elles ont pas été elles
ont pas été censurées au fond et ben
tentons à nouveau le coup on va avoir un
projet de loi à priori sur la me Gabriel
Atal s'est engagé à suivre la voie
d'Élisabeth Bor dans la matière et ben
élargissons le projet de loi et tout ce
qui a été censuré au titre du cavalier
mettons-le dans le texte et s'il y a un
problème de constitionalité et bien
réformons la
Constitution et donc ça veut dire que
sur ces sujets bah on na sans doute pas
fini encore d'en parler la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel n'est pas
vraiment un point final en la matière
ouai mais ça veut pas dire pour autant
pour être bien clair que le juge
constitutionnel avec cette décision
s'est substitué au législateur c'est pas
substitué au législateur mais si vous
voulez le Conseil constitutionnel c'est
le gardien des droits fondamentaux c'est
vrai mais à l'origine dans la contion de
58 c'est d'abord le garde des
parlementaires c'est celui qui doit
faire que les parlementaires et bien
n'empiètent pas sur les platbandes de
l'exécutif or quand vous lancez un
projet de loi en tant qu'exécutif vous
avez une idée et cette idée-là et bien
lorsque vous la lancez au Parlement vous
ne souhaitez pas que on vous mette des
amendements qui n'ont rien à voir le
Conseil constitutionnel se fait le
gardien du texte de l'exécutif faut que
ce texte là il échappe pas au
gouvernement que vous retrouviez pas à
l'origine avec un texte sur les carrotes
trapés et que vous finissiez avec un
texte sur le fromage il y a quand même
pas mal d'hypocrisie à tous les étages
Christopher weisberg vous allez me dire
c'est parfait cette décision je suis
soulagé je vais vous montrer en un
dessin euh un petit peu ce qu'on
comprend de la situation dans la
majorité c'est le dessin de CaC euh dans
l'opinion ce matin je sais pas si vous
l'avez vu c'est Emmanuel Macron qui
glisse à Laurent Fabius le président du
Conseil constitutionnel j'ai surligné
les passages que j'ai fait semblant
d'accepter je compte sur vous pour les
censurer il y a un Paris stratégique
gagnant vous attendiez euh toutes ces
censures non oui en partie euh
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que je me suis
abstenu c'est pour ça que le président
de la commission des lois sa chaoulier a
a voté contre euh il avait été très
clair euh la plupart des dispositions il
avait présenté en commission des lois
une semaine avant la motion de rejet qui
nous a pas permis d'aller au bout du
texte et c'était ces dispositions qui
ont été ajoutées par le Sénat elles
seront contraires à la Constitution au
terme de l'arti mais pour les gens qui
nous regardent pour vos électeurs pour
les Français c'est inaudible c'est
incompréhensible la très grande majorité
de votre groupe a voté les quotas
d'immigration on voté les restrictions
d'allocation familiale ont voté la la
remise en cause de l'automaticité du
droit du sol et j'en passe donc vous
dites tant mieux mais on a voté mais
mais mais c'est pas clair ça c'est pas
un travail de conviction je vaisêtre
très très très clair avec vous au final
il y a le texte il est arrivé il y a un
an il est sorti un projet de loi qui
venait du gouvernement avec des éléments
qui avaient été sur les deux jambes on
avait dit il y avait d'un côté Dér
régularisations et ça ça allait plutôt
dans le sens de l'intégration et puis il
y avait un contrôle ardu c'était dans le
texte initiale et toutes les personnes
dans la majorité étaient plutôt
favorable à ça moi j'y étais très
favorable pour pour moi c'était la
philosophie même de ce texte qui va dans
le sens je pense de du bon sens de ce
que l'on veut faire je rappelle quand
même que à gauche aussi François
mitteran Michel recard ils ont toujours
été assez constants sur ces pointsl sur
le fait que les irréguliers il fallait
pas qu'il puissent rester en France mais
qu'il fallait avoir une politique
d'intégration qui était efficace pour
moi ça n'a absolument rien ce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'il a eu un jeu politique
et vous le savez très bien parce que on
a eu ce débat là je me souviens il y a y
a avant la avant la trêve parlementaire
il y a eu un jeu politique des sénateurs
puis deslr qui ont essayé de pousser la
mécanique jusqu'au bout il y avait une
position qui aurait été aussi très
insatisfaisante qui était de dire
puisqu'on a pas de majorité
absoluej sommes pas une majorité absolue
nous ne sommes pas de la majorité qui
était de 2017 à 2022 et qui avait les
moyens de mener toutes les réformes
qu'elle voulait comme elle le souhaitait
et bien ce jeul des républicains il a
été sanctionné par les LR par le
camoufler pour les républicains je vais
quand même aller les voir et je viens
vous voir tout suite après Benjamin
lucat Anne lorblin c'est la lecture
politique que vous faites ce soir de
cette décision c'est vrai que tous vos
apports sont réduit en poussière ce
soir c'est très intéressant d'entendre
les les interventions des des
intervenants en plateau parce que
effectivement la la jurisprudence du
Conseil constitutionnel l'article 45
c'est de juger si il y a un lien même
indirect avec le texte et donc ça
démontre bien cette décision du Conseil
constitutionnel combien en réalité le
projet initial du gouvernement était une
vague de régularisation massive tandis
que notre projet était lui un projet
pour veiller à préserver la France et
les Français des vous allez faire au
Républicain vous ne voterez plus jamais
avec cette
majoritéctionn quelle conséquence
politique vous tirez à l'Assemblée c'est
vrai que vous avez arraché ce compromis
est-ce que ça vous dissuade de voter les
textes à venir non mais ce qui est
certain c'est que euh la détermination
qui est la notre reste intacte mais moi
ma déception elle est profonde pour les
Français parce qu'en réalité le
gouvernement les macronistes ont joué
effectivement vous avez raison de dire
un jeu de dupe parce que ce texte
initialement présenté a été profondément
remodifié par le travail des sénateurs
et par le travail à l'Assemblée
nationale par le vote des représentants
euh du peuple français et le
gouvernement ne l'a clairement mais
clairement pas défendu auprès du Conseil
donc vous demandez une révision
constitutionnelle qui on présenté pardon
je termine mais ce sont les députés les
républicains qui ont présenté un mémoire
en défense de ce texte qui était
effectivement profondément important
pour garantir et préserver l'avenir de
la France et endiguer cette vague de
subversion migratoire que nous refusons
pour le pays juste pour bien comprendre
la suite pour les républicains c'est
quoi c'est de reprendre tout ce qui a
été considéré comme cavalier donc
censurer sur la forme et est proposé
dans des propositions de loi c'est ça
pourquoi pas dans le texte de sur l'aide
médicale d'État la suite nous l'avons
annoncé dès le départ si nous voulons
véritablement
garantir une protection français il nous
faut une réforme constitutionnel et je
crois que la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel nous le démontre
véritablement très bien ce soir et donc
évidemment nous voulons une réforme
constitutionnelle encore hier on parlait
d'une réforme de la Constitution pour un
sujet complètement anecdotique qui
n'intéresse pas du tout les Français la
réforme de la constitutionnalisation de
l'IVG donc saisissons cette réforme de
l'IVG s'il le souhait mett dit mais les
sondages ne montr pas les mêmes choses
sur que nous subirons plus l'immigration
et donc faisons cette réforme
constitutionnelle comme l'appel de leur
vœux les républicains alors encore
faut-il en avoir les moyens on
l'impression que personne n'a perdu ce
soir Benjamin Lucas vous est-ce que vous
êtes quand même un peu soulagé je
rappelle que les écologistes avaient
déposé une motion de rejet après tout
s'il y avait eu un débat peut-être qu'on
en serait pas là on pourra refaire le
film si vous voulez la réalité
arithmétique et parlementaire aurait pas
changé qu'on ait eu une après-midi de
débat avec la motion de rejetou 15 jours
puisqueà la fin le gouvernement aurait
dû quand même chercher à trouver une
majorité la réalité c'est que ça
commence bien le réarmement civique là
avec les sousdouets de la Constitution
on a quand même eu pardon mais un truc
un peu à la Trump qui s'est passé c'est
un ministre de l'Intérieur qui vient à
la tribune de l'Assemblée nationale dire
ce que vous allez voter est
inconstitutionnel et une majorité qui
préfère faire de la loi de la républ
publque un tracte des obsessions de
l'extrême droite famille Le Pen
perrefille confondu qui revendique une
victoire idéologique et donc il en
restera c'est ça la question de votre
émission qu'est-ce qui va rester de
cette loi il va rester une faillite
morale terrible pour la macronie c'est
d'avoir pour la première fois depuis la
Seconde Guerre mondiale voter un texte
sur l'immigration avec le soutien de
l'extrême droite c'est ça qui reste
aujourd'hui quel que soit le soulagement
juridique nous avons aujour'hu étrang
situation il rien il reste rien pardon
le texte issu de la commission des lois
il reste rien sur les régularisations la
preuve c'est que LR a pu le voter à la
fin ce texte d'accord et que Marine le a
dit c'est une victoire idéologique qui
reste quelques régularisations dans
quelques métiers entention pour une
période expérimentale c'est pas du tout
la prise en compte de la réalité
aujourd'hui des travailleurs sans papier
dans dans notre vie économique pour vous
sur les objectifs du texte intégré par
le travail mieuxexpulser ceux qui n'ont
pas en France si vous permettez ce ce
qui reste et qui est grave c'est que le
Président de la République a failli à sa
tâche la mission du président de la
République dans la 5e République c'est
d'être le gardien des institutions or
aujourd'hui on a quoi on a toute une
partie de la droite radicalisée et
l'extrême droite qui dit disent et bien
il faut mettre à bas le Conseil
constitutionnel il faut qui fait de la
politique
réision gouvernement des juges et cetera
la réalité c'est que la réalité c'est
que le Président de la République qui
devait être gardien des institutions et
qui avait été élu sur la promesse du
barrage républicain et humaniste à
l'extrême droite a non seulement échoué
de ce point de vue-là puisqu'il a fait
entrer des pentiers du programme de
l'extrême droite raciste dans la loi
qu'il a entretenu un racisme
l'atmosphère à travers des débats
noséabons auquels nous avons assisté et
qu'en plus il a fait la démonstration
d'un amateurisme qui contredit ce qui
était la promesse de professionnalisme
on nous a dit en 2017 vous allez voir
c'est les technocrates au pouvoir donc
d'accord il y a plus de gauche il y a
plus de droite il y a plus d'idées il y
a que des opportunistes mais au moins
ils connaissent leur affaires il
connaissent leur métier la vérité c'est
que ce sont des gens qui ont fait voter
une loi anticonstitutionnelle en le
sachant parfaitement tout ça est
lamentable et ne contribue pas à dire à
nos constitoyens que ce que nous faisons
ici à l'Assemblée nationale vous allez
très loin vous vous dites même que
l'État de droit serait quasiment en
péril à vous à vous entendre le regard
deoc pardon je dis que en ce moment on
couvre les les primaires américaines
monsieur Trump est le genre de
personnage qui dit on peut faire des
choses qui sont inconstitutionnelles
c'est exactement ce qu'on fait monsieur
Macron et Monsieur Darmanin il y a une
trumpisation de la macronie aujourd'hui
qui moins m'inquiète comme républicain
et comme citoyen qui a fait barage à de
reprisou Ch là il faut qu'il réagisse
sur la trumpisation Christopher weisberg
et je vous donne la parole juste après
maître Goldman non mais la trumpisation
c'est exacte à la rigueur que vous que
vous puissiez dire que quand le Eric
cotti ou les républicains expliquent que
le Conseil constitutionnel n'est pas
légitime là je peux comprendre qu'on
s'attaque à la légitimité de notre
Constitution et de nos tion ce qui
pourrait ressembler à Trump et
franchement je vous enarde le trumpisme
c'est autre chose c'est une un projet
révolutionnaire d'extrême droite si vous
considérez qu'on est des
révolutionnaires d'extrême droite
j'aimerais bien que vous puissiez éer la
loi immigration pardon les dispositions
que vos amis on voté vous avez
courage commission des lois on revient
Tex de la commission des lois et que
vous avez porté vous-même une motion de
rejet préalable pouron ne puisse pas on
ne puisse pas travailler sur ce texte
dans tout dispositions qu'on avait la
commission des lois les quotas les
quotas c'était dans le texte de la
commission des lois vous avez repris des
propositions déjà de la droite
radicalisée de l'extrême droite D la
commission des lois donc alors les cotas
c'est la jurisprudence c'est
inconstitutionnel ça personne ne pourra
jamais plus faire pour voté en
commission c'est réglé c'est réglé en
effet mais pour des raison
essentiellement lié à la séparation des
pouvoirs hein donc ça veut pas dire
Paron n'ose pas un débat au Parlement
exactement c'estàdire que le Parlement
n'envoie pas des injonctions au
gouvernement et que on n'impose pas non
plus au Parlement de débattre sur tel ou
tel sujet donc à partir de là ça veut
pas dire que le
si le gouvernement décide de cotas on
est sur autre chose c'est très clair
j'aimerais parce que c'est pas un duel
non plus faire circuler un peu la parole
et puis ensuite la lecture politique
maître Goldman vous pensez que les
Français vont comprendre un petit peu ce
qui se passe c'est un peu ce que je
voulais dire bon je suis là comme avocat
je suis privatiste je suis pas
publiciste donc je je bois les paroles
du professeur Dr constitutionnel mais
c'est vrai que les Français moyens parce
que moi je préside des fondations qui
travaillent dans le domaine social
éducatif culturel je pense P qu'il vont
pas comprendre grandchose ce soir déjà
quand on est juriste on a un peu de mal
deux remarques mais pr pas
l'intelligence des
citoyens tout mais ce qu' vont remarquer
les citoyens c'est que c'est pas la les
premiers qui ont voté avec le
rassemblement national c'est la nupes
dans d'autres la dernière législature
donc vous avez habitué le
par pas acceptable de dire qu'on est
allié du rassemblement national Mo j'ai
jamais j'ai jamais repris propos
non c'est pas acceptable c'est pas
acceptable c'est pas la même chose de
voter une motion de procédure déposée
par nous et de voter leur texte en
sementaris ce qui me gêne c'est
l'antiparlementaris de circonstance et
ce qui me gêne également énormément
c'est qu'on puisse et là c'est pas vous
jeter l'eau propre sur le Conseil
constitutionnel qui est le garant de nos
institutions qui a dé créé pour garantir
la faisabilité ou non d'une loi que ce
soit par des moyens techniques comme
aujourd'hui mais nous aussi qu comme
avocat on a souvent des décisions de
justice dans les tribunaux où on a une
recevabilité un défaut d'intérêt à agir
c'est un problème technique qui empêche
un jugement d'être rendu et c'est pas la
ch pas de tribunal par l'image du
Conseil constitutionnel on se souvient
des vœux de Laurent Fabius qui avait
clairement tensé Emmanuel Macron en lui
disant nous ne sommes pas une chambre
d'appel du Parlement Elsa mondagava qui
n'a pas encore parler la lecture
politique il y a un gagnant ce soir on
se dit que tout le monde perd non bah un
peu parce qu'en fait alors il y a un
soulagement pour les opposants à cette
loi évidemment mais il y a une fracture
une rupture une blessure même dans la
majorité parce qu'il y a quand même des
députés de la majorité qui ont voté
cette loi donc ça gagne toujours et puis
il y a aussi la droite qui se sent
évidemment trahie déçu des négociations
mais qui elle va pouvoir bah redire le
problème c'est bien la Constitution le
problème c'est que le politique n'est
pas capable d'imposer quelque chose mais
en fait la duplicité elle existait nous
on avait suivi les négociations en
coulisse entre la droite et la majorité
et en fait il savaient dès le début que
ça allait être inconstitutionnel mais en
fait ça semblait ne déranger personne
c'est-à-dire qu'on on disait à la
majorité mais après si c'est retoqué qu'
allez-vous faire ah bah si si il a droit
de veut et B tant pis ce sera retoqué au
constitutionnel ce sera tant pis pour
elle et quand on le disait à la droite
mais vous allez bien voir qu'à la fin le
Conseil constitutionnel il va les
enlever et ben ils avaient l'air de
vouloir quand même maintenir prouver
cette volonté donc en fait le résultat
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas surprenant on en
parlait lors des négociations de la
commission mixte paritaire dès le début
en nous disant mais ça de toute façon ça
ne passera pas les fourchec du cons qui
dé plaît àurent Fabius c'est qu'au fond
on est on l' pris un peu en otage cette
institution c'est ces neuf stages vous
êtes d'accord avec cette analyse on
prend totalement en otage l'institution
et ce qui a été dit est très très fort
et très très vrai c'est-à-dire que vous
avez des dispositions qui sont
manifestement inconstitutionnelles ne
serait-ce que parce que c'est des
cavaliers on le savait c'était pas une
nouveauté mais vous attendez que le
Conseil censure et s sû une partie
importante de votre loi ça permet à la
droite d'envoyer des signaux politiques
ça permet à la majorité et bien d'avoir
son texte en temps et en heure mais
derrière celui qui va se prendre
aujourd'hui une volée de bois vert de la
part de toute une partie d'opposition
c'est qui c'est le Conseil
constitutionnel alors que sur le fond et
bien il n'avait guère le choix sauf à
renverser totalement sa jurisprudence
que de censurer les dispositions coup de
force des juges c'est l'expression de
Jordan Bardella coup de force des juges
avec le soutien d'Emmanuel Macron vous
pensez que euh ça va porter ces mots-là
dans sur l'institution sur la séparation
des pouvoirs et le plan était déjà un
petit peu là c'est-à-dire que la censure
allait avoir lieu et donc ce faisant il
faut relancer le débat sur l'immigration
en vue des européennes et donc si jamais
la la la loi est censuré et bien à ce
moment-là il faut demander une révision
constitutionnelle c'est intéressant
d'ailleurs de voir les réactions les
premières réactions qui sortent c'est
révision la Constitution le Conseil a
été assez malin avec son affaire de
cavalier parce qu'aujourd'hui il ne nous
dit pas si les dispositions en question
sont sur le fond institutionnel d'un
point de vue purement légal la bonne
réaction serait de dire mais écoutez
proposons un autre projet de loi ayant
pour focal justement ces disposition là
et on verra bien si ça passe non on
s'attaque directement à la constitution
parce que là-dessus vous voyez on est
plus dans le plan com que vraiment dans
la construction politique bien compris
Anne lorblin c'est moins facile vous
êtes à distance vous nous écoutez depuis
votre circonscription on disait coup de
force hein les mots sont très forts du
rassemblement national sont-ils
démocratiques selon vous ces ces mots-là
non mais entendre les propos de votre
plateau je suis atterré enfin ces
militants écologistes de salon qui
viennent la France et RAC et xénophobes
c'est une profonde insulte aux Français
les Français attendentun vraie réforme
ambitieuse sur la question de
l'immigration notre travail profond
depuis de longs mois avec le Sénat et
avec notre groupe les républicains a été
de proposer un certain nombre de mesures
qui répondent justement à leurs attentes
il y a un certain nombre de décisions
mais complètement compréhensible du
Conseil constitutionnel une insulte
profonde aux Français qui encore une
fois sont dans une attente légitime et à
qui on a dit que finalement on ne
pouvait absolument rien faire donc je
crois qu'il faut arrêter ces discours
d'autoatisfaction de je renvoie la balle
ici ou là je crois qu'il faut
véritablement reprendre dès le départ le
la teneur et les tenants des enjeux qui
nous attendent et qui attendent la
France parce que aujourd'hui nous sommes
en train de créer un véritable creusé
entre une sorte de caste politique
particulièrement bien représenté sur
votre plateau et les Français qui
veulent véritablement des mesures de
terrain très concrètes cette déconnexion
de notre collègue député écologiste qui
aujourd'hui alors même qu'il y a un
mouvement de profond dans le pays une
gronde une colère énorme de nos
agriculteurs montre à quel point ils ne
comprennent pas ce que les Français
souhaitent et notre travail nous le comp
continueront quoi qu'il en soit cette
réforme constitutionnelle nous y
aboutirons parce que c'est l'intérêt des
Français et de la France de sauvegarder
ce qui est encore possible dans ce pays
pour demain et pour l'avenir de notre
pays merci beaucoup Anne lorblin
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez
puisqu'elle vous met en cause sur
l'écologie de Sal j'ai battu un député
sortant à l' qui a fait 7 % en premier
tour elle dit elle dit les Français
attendent une réforme d'leur sur
l'immigration j'ai pas très bien compris
le lien entre la GRE des agriculteurs et
la question question l'immigration je
pense qu'il faut raison garder dans
cette affaire non mais on assiste à
quelque chose d'intéressant c'est que
enfin d'intéressant de dramatique mais
d'intéressant c'est c'est la
droitisation du débat public moi je
crois qu'on a une classe politique
beaucoup plus raciste et xénophobe que
que les Françaises et les Français je
crois qu'il y a une aspiration dans
notre pays à la fraternité je crois
qu'aujourd'hui une aspiration à
l'égalité notamment via des réformes
ambitieuses sur le pouvoir d'achat et en
tout cas que c'est pas notre rôle de
verser à cela et vous avez là unel
rédigé pour vous étaé raciste moi oui
sur quel point en tout cas il a
contribué à mettre dans dans la société
un racisme d'atmosphère à travers le le
débat qui existait oui pardon mais mais
mais euh le la préférence nationale le
la fin d'automaticité du droit du sol
par exemple le cautionnement pour les
étudiants étrangers tout ça pour moi
participe d' d'une forme de xénophobie
euh évidemment d'ailleurs Madame Le Pen
a dit victoire idéologique de l'extrême
droite euh mais que vous que vous ayez
une pardon mais moi je j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit moi qui soit
particulièrement déconnecté moi je
m'inspire par exemple de ce que dit
Jacques Toubon qui a été secrétaire
général du RPR voyez euh je suis pas
secteur je regarde ce qui se dit aussi
euh euh dans la société et ce que disent
notamment un certain nombre de de
défenseurs des libertés euh des des des
droits fondamentaux ce que disent un
certain nombre de d'organisations
internationales mais voir une
parlementaire d'un parti qui jadis a été
un parti de gouvernement euh qui
explique aujourd'hui que finalement nous
vivrions sous la menace de l'immigration
et qui reprend des discours
historiquement portés par l'extrême
droite il n'y a qu'à voir où on est à
l'air dans les dans les sondages pour
les élections européennes pour voir
qu'en plus ça ne marche pas deur ce
sujet est tellement clivant
l'immigration on le retrouve sur ce
plateau et c'est pas un épilogue parce
qu'on on on on comprend bien que il
pourrait y avoir des suites je vous
redonne la parole mais on va faire le
tour d'horizon des réactions ce soir à
cette décision recueillie par Marco
Pomier à l'Assemblée et on vous retrouve
juste après pour terminer ce
débat la réalité c'est qu'Emmanuel
Macron a fait preuve de duplicité il a
trompé on l'a trompé les républicains
les députés les républicains il a
surtout trompé les Françaises et les
Français il demande à ses députés de
voter un texte de loi il soutient ce
texte de loi al des émissions de
télévision auquelles il participe pour
ensuite demander et saisir lui-même le
Conseil constitutionnel et faire envoyer
par le Secrétariat général du
gouvernement un mémo un mémoire de 20
points pour demander la censure d'au
moins 20 dispositifs ce deux po de
mesure cette ambiguïé du président de la
République cela suffit et nous demandons
expressément aujourd'hui au président de
la République au ministre de l'Intérieur
et au Premier ministre de présenter une
loi immigration 2 derrière la
mystification l'amateurisme du
gouvernement c'est bien la question de
réaffirmer la volonté du peuple Français
par référendum en modifiant la
Constitution pour que notre loi
souveraine d'une part soit supérieure au
traités européens mais aussi pour
réinterpréter pour redonner toute la
force de la décision de la volonté
populaire face au Conseil
constitutionnel qui s'y soumettra
évidemment puisque le Conseil
constitutionnel sait très bien que le
vrai juge suprême dans la 5e République
c'est le peuple français bon déjà oui
c'est un camouflé pour le gouvernement
il me semble que il serait mieux à ce
niveau-là de carrément retirer cette loi
le Conseil constitutionnel a battu en
brèche toutes les idées que Monsieur
Macron était allé puiser directement
dans le programme de Madame Le Pen bonne
nouvelle pour la République française au
minimum c'est déjà ça de prix le
gouvernement a voulu faire un bras
d'honneur au Parlement le Conseil
constitutionnel le renvoie dans ses
cordes et c'est et c'est bien mérité
maintenant des problèmes de fond
demeurent c'est l'intention de ce
gouvernement qui est allé sur le terrain
de l'extrême droite voilà on retrouve
exactement les les tonalités sur sur sur
ce plateau Elsa la question maintenant
c'est la révision constitutionnelle on
va entendre ça dans la bouche de Marine
Le Pen et dans la bouche d'éicotti d dès
ce soir les oppositions de droite
ont-elles les moyens de l'obtenir cette
révision non elles n'en ont absolument
pas les moyens quand on voit que c'est
même difficile pour la majorité
d'obtenir une révision constitutionnelle
non puisquon le rappelle déjà c'est très
difficile de modifier la Constitution
faut soit qu'un un texte soit voté dans
les mêmes termes par l'Assemblée par le
Sénat et ensuite un congrès donc non ils
n'en ont absolument pas les moyens mais
j'ai envie de dire ça coûte pas très
cher de le dire quand même puisqu'on
peut dire qu'on est bloqué qu'on ne peut
rien faire on renvoie à une éventuelle
révision dont on sait pertinemment
qu'elle ne pourra pas avoir lieu que des
postures finalement dans ce débat ou
derrière ce débat Benjamin Morel on
parle aussi de référendum sur
l'immigration ça n'est pas prévu par la
Constitution c'est question de société
ça n'est pas prévu c'està-dire que vous
avez des champs du référendum dans la
Constitution et l'immigration c'est un
thème c'est pas vraiment un champ c'est
pas vraiment un domaine on pourrait
imaginer éventuellement un référendum
sur l'immigration économique sur
certaines disposition i revanche par
exemple le volet pénal ça c'est exclu le
volet civil c'est également exclu si
vous vouliez faire un référendum sur le
sujet faudrait d'abord modifier la
Constitution et l'option de Goul
c'est-à-dire on fait un référendum
constitutionnel et donc on se passe de
l'avis du Parlement aujourd'hui n'est
plus possible il y a eu une évolution de
la jurisprudente du Conseil consel en
2005 qui fait que le Conseil bloquerait
l'affaire en amont donc en effet à ce
stade là on voit pas vraiment de
référendum possible sur l'immigration
beaucp d'obstacles à Fran en revanche la
révision constitutionnelle c'est en
effet un bon argument électoral pour la
campagne européenne et si on se place du
point de vue stratégique l'objectif
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est qu'on parle pas
d'immigration pendant la campagne
européenne ça c'est raté excellente
conclusion elle est pour vous cette
question Christopher weisberg elle
revient il revient ce thème de
l'immigration vous pensiez l'avoir
derrière vous cette réforme mais en fait
pas du tout en fait je suis désolé mais
là au contraire moi je pense que c'est
l'épilogue d'un épisode et puis vous
avez dit tout à l'heure qui sont les
gagnants c'est vrai ça ça nous ça nous
fait presque une abstraction par rapport
au vrai débat qu'est-ce qu'il va
apporter au français il y a un texte le
texte on revient à l'original le texte
qui sont les gagnants bah c'est les
travailleurs qui sont dans des
restaurant et qui aujourd'hui ne
pouvaent pas avoir un titre de séjour
ceux-là ils sont gagnants les gagnants
c'est ver combien de préont de ça par
mineurs les mineurs en centre de
réttention administrative qui sont dans
des conditions et qui sont sortis grâce
à ce texte eux c'est les gagnants et
puis les
gagnants pas les jeunes majeurs qui vont
se retrouver à la rue pas les jeunes
majeurs qui vont se retrouver à la rue
dans quelqu une chose on va attendre
c'est c'est ceux qui ont l'entré en
vigueur du texte pour vous réinviter et
puis pour voir un peu le le premier
bilan qu'on peut tirer ela le mot de la
fin pas l'épilogue puisqueil y aura un
texte sur l'ame donc on aura encore
l'occasion
de merci beaucoup j'espère qu'on a été
clair pour nos téléspectateurs parce que
le débat il est juridique il est
complexe il est très politique on l'a
bien compris merci à vous vous restez
avec moi Ariel Goldman dans une dizaine
de minutes les parties prix de nos
affranchis ce soir qui sont les classes
moyennes le regard de Thomas Lestavel
sur l'étude de l'instit situe Montaigne
qui a abattu l'avion russe avec 65
prisonniers Ukrainiens à bord Isabelle
lasser revient sur les circonstances du
crash qui a eu lieu à la frontière entre
les deux pays hier et puis quel est le
menu de Bourbon Express Stéphanie des
piierr ce soir 300 € de plus pour les
députés pour payer leurs frais ça fait
polémique ouais cette rallonge fait
polémique c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire à tout à l'heure les amis mais
d'abord on va se pencher sur l'explosion
des acte antisémite avec vous Ariel
Goldman on assiste en France à un
véritable déferlement depuis le 7
octobre alors de quels actes parle-t-on
précisément qui en sont les auteurs quel
est le carburant de cette flambée
d'antisémitisme regardz c'est dans
l'invitation d'Hélène monduel interview
juste
après si on vous invite Ariel Goldman
c'est pour évoquer ses images des murs
tagués des tombes juifes profanées des
synagogues ciblées les actes antisémites
n'ont jamais été aussi nombreux en
France 1676 recens en 2023 contre 436 en
2022 c'est le CRIF le Conseil
représentatif des institutions juives de
France que vous avez coprésidé qui
publie ses chiffres un antisémitisme qui
a explosé depuis le 7 octobre dernier et
l'attaque terroriste du Hamas en Israël
une hausse de plus de 1000 % par rapport
aux 3 années précédentes le regain de de
violence qu'il y a là-bas c'est oui
c'est c'est une des raisons qui pousse
les communautés à se à se taper dessus
en France trop régulièrement alors que
très souvent c'est pour des mauvaises
raisons plus de la moitié sont des
atteintes directes aux personnes le
député Jérôme Gedge en a fait les frais
récemment en recevant des lettres de
menace et ça ça a été la goutte d'eau
parce que j'avais reçu quelques jours
auparavant ce petit montage où voilà où
je suis un et je me suis dit il
faut en parler c'est le député de la
République qui s'exprime moi je suis un
universaliste républicain voilà donc je
je je le fais comme n'importe qui
devrait le faire dès qu'il est confronté
à une manifestation de racisme et
d'antisémitisme le député vient
d'ailleurs de porter plainte le CRIF lui
demande plus de fermeté face à ces actes
qui se multiplient on manque de de
caractère exemplaire et de de de de on
va dire publicité sur les suites
judiciaires qui sont données je pense
qu'on gagnerait à ce que les cas de
condamnation sévères sur l'antisémitisme
il y en a eu quelquesuns et bien soi
mieux connu pour que on restaure un peu
le caractère dissuasif de l'État de
droit alors face à cette montée de
l'antisémitisme nous avons une question
pour vous Ariel Goldman quel sursaut
attendez-vous de la société
française
réponse je veux dire deux choses d'abord
je vais répondre bien sûr à votre
question qui est fondamentale quel
sursaut qu'est-ce qu'on fait est-ce
qu'on se dit dans le fond bah c'est
comme ça il y en avait 400 l'année
dernière ce qui est déjà énorme c'est
plus que un par jour il y en a eu 1600
sur 202 3 c'est presque 5 par jour mais
derrière ces chiffres qui sont glaçants
il y a des femmes il y a des hommes il y
a des enfants qui sont atteints dans
leur identité dans leur atteinte dans
leur intégrité physique parfois
puisqu'il y a beaucoup d'actes physique
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose que je voudrais dire c'est que le
7 octobre évidemment est un tournant
évidemment est un marqueur mais les
actes antisémites surgissent dès le 7
octobre comme ils avaient surgi après
Toulouse en 2012 comme ils avaient surgi
après l'hypercacher en 2015 avanté en
guerre avant l'entrée en guerre de Salal
bien sûr complètement décorrélé ce qui
veut dire qu'on a un terreau un fond qui
est complètement prêt à à sauter sur
l'occasion si vous me passez
l'expression et également ce qui veut
dire que la médiatisation d'actes
antijuifs comme Toulouse comme
l'hypercacher comme lespogrome du 7
octobre en Israël et bien ont un effet
booster sur les antisémites qui passent
à l'acte et quelqu'un a dit dans votre
sujet ces communautés qui se montent les
unes contre les autres c'est pas vrai il
y a une communauté qui est agressée
c'est la communauté juive il y a des
synagogues qui sont visées et
aujourd'hui on en vient au milieu
scolaire dans l'enquête que le SPCJ via
le CRIF a a publié dans l'étude annuelle
on pensait que c'était un sanctuaire ça
ça ça n'est plus le le cas ilel 12,1 %
des actes qui ont lieu en milieu
scolaire ou scolaire ça a pénétré les
foyers on a vu les boîtes aux lettres
les mésousotes ces petits boîtiers que
les gens ont eu peur de conserver parce
qu'ils ont eu peur d'être attaqués et
moi je suis au contact de sur les Pali
de porte vous avez raison je suis
vousmême vous l'avez vous l'avez senti
vous l'avez subbi non moi j'ai pas senti
au niveau de la de la Mousa mais j'ai
bien sûr reçu des menaces également
Jérôme gage reçoit des menaces il y a
elbron Piva reçu des menaces mais
combien d'anonymes reçoivent dans leurs
boîte aux lettres des menaces et ce qui
est dramatique je vais vous le dire
c'est que il faut un sursaut national
alors justement la société française
dans son ensemble elle n'est pas
antisémite elle demande d'ailleurs à ce
qu'on combatte toute forme
d'antisémitisme quand on regarde les
sondages d'opinion mais est-ce que la
réprobation sociale est à la hauteur
est-ce qu'on n'est pas en train de
s'habituer est-ce que vous trouvez que
ça offusque vraiment ben on s'habitue
mais on s'habitue d'ailleurs quand on
donne les chiffres parce qu'on on
s'ofusque d'être passé de 400 à 1676
mais ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure c'est que 400 c'est déjà énorme
et c'est comme ça depuis 2003 on
s'habitue parce que dans les foyers on
s'habitue il faut rien laisser passer
que ce soit dans le milieu
famili pas la réponse judiciaire parce
que il y a des plaintes qui sont
déposées il y a des interpellations et
il y a des condamnations mais la société
française est-ce que vous la trouvez à
la hauteur face à ce phénomène cette
déferlante est-ce que vous trouvez que
elle elle est elle est dans une
réprobation suffisante pas vraiment il y
a le sécuritaire où il y a eu des
efforts importants qui ont été faits par
les différents ministres de l'Intérieur
et notamment géralde Darmanin qui a dès
le 7 octobre déployé des policiers et
cetera ça c'est une réponse il y a une
réponse judiciaire qui existe mais qui
n'est pas assez connue on ne connaît pas
assez les résultats de la poursuite
judiciaire des actes antisémites qui
sont je le rappelle des délits
l'antisémitisme c'est pas une opinion
c'est un délit c'est une maladie c'est
un cancer mais c'est un délit aussi en
France depuis longtemps et effectivement
il y a un manque de réaction de la
société il y a eu cette grande marche du
mois de novembre à laquelle certains
partis politiques ont refusé de
participer et à la fin de cette marche
président de la République oui mais
enfin tout son gouvernement était
représenté c'est pas un parti qui a
refusé de participer et à la fin de
cette marche le président Larchet qui
avait initié avec Madame Bron pivé cette
marche a dit il y a eu la marche il faut
des démarches et ces démarches
effectivement il faut qu'elles soient au
sein de toute la société française
souvenez-vous à l'époque du président
Chirac il y avait un fléo c'était la
mortalité sur la route et bien tout le
monde s'y est mis le législateur s'y est
mis le conducteur s'y est mis le le
buveur d'alcool s'y est mis il faut que
tout le monde s'y mette sinon on va pas
y arriver sinon on va s'habituer et tous
les ans on donnera des chiffres avec à
la clé quand même je veux le dire je
veux le redire des morts plus de 10
morts d'actes antisémites bien sûr et et
d'ailleurs voilà des morts en France pas
de depuis le 7 octobre on est bien
d'accord depuis le 7 octobre mais on
peut bien sûr et tant mieux et grâce à
Dieu mais on ne peut pas oublier
l'affaire de Toulouse qui est le premier
assassinat d'enfants juifs depuis la
guerre qui est le premier assassinat
dans une école les enfants Sandler je
salue la mémoire d'ailleurs de Samuel
Sandler le père et le grand-père qui est
décédé il a quelques jours donc j'étais
très proche et l'avocat et il y a eu
mirnol il y a eu Sarah Alimi il y a eu
Ilan Alimi je vais pas rappeler mais
enfin
l'antisémitisme tue en France alors
l'antisémitisme tue en France
aujourd'hui on a cette déferlante
d'actes antisémite on est sur des
agressions physiques insulte atteinte à
la personne plus qu'au bien ce sont les
chiffres de l'étude qui sont les auteurs
est-ce que le fait que on connaisse un
un boom spectaculaire depuis le 7
octobre ça éclaire sur sur les auteurs
bah alors c'est qu'en France on n pas de
statistique ethnique des auteurs ni dans
la police ni dans la justice donc on ne
sait pas Infiné qui sont les auteurs
mais c'est vrai que les auteurs sont
souvent depuis le 7 octobre des
personnes qui sont qui se sentent
finalement épouser la cause du Hamas ou
des Palestiniens et qui passe à l'acte
mais c'est ce qu'on fait Koulibali et
Mera quand Koulibali et Mera ont commis
leurs assassinats de juifs ils se sont
aussi revendiqué de la cause
palestinienne donc il y a beaucoup de
personnes dans ces auteurs je n'ai pas
toutes les statistiques tous les
résultats des décisions de justice qui
ne se cachent pas d'ailleurs sur les
réseaux sociaux j'ai un dernier point
peut-être parce qu'on n pas beaucoup de
temps encore mais il y a plus grave que
les chiffres d'aujourd'hui il y a les
réactions sur les réseaux sociaux à ces
chiffres il y a les complotistes qui se
moquentil faut préciser que dans ces
chiffres ne sont pas pris les réseaux
sociaux ne sont pas pris en compte les
réseaux sociaux seul les plaintes ou les
signalements sont pris en compte et donc
là si on tient compte des réseaux
sociaux là on arrive à on à des dizaines
de milliers parce que la plateforme
Faros D ement elle a pas les moyens
humains de traiter tous les signalements
mais quand vous voyez les réactions sur
les réseaux sociaux entre les
complotistes qui minimisent entre ceux
qui font de l'antisémitisme sur la
dénonciation des actes antisémites c'est
effroyable comment on fait pour casser
cette idée parfois installer dans dans
la tête de certaines personnes que ce
qui se passe au Proche Orient n'a
absolument rien à voir avec les les
Français
juifs si j'avais la réponse je vous la
donnerai
c'est un mal qui s'est installé depuis
de nombreuses années en France on a vu
les manifestations lors d'autres
opérations à Gaza en 2014 notamment avec
des cris de mort aux Juifs dans les rues
de Paris il y a finalement cette
assimilation Israël égal juif juif égal
Israël alors c'est vrai que beaucoup de
membres de la communauté dont je me
reconnais sont solidaires des Israéliens
et encore plus solidaire depuis le drame
qui leur est arrivé le 7 octobre mais
être solidaire ne veut pas dire passer à
l'acte sur qui que ce soit et ce que je
condamne moi ce que je déplore en tant
que responsable de la communauté juive
et tant que citoyen tout simplement
c'est que parce qu'on a de l'empathie
pour un peuple bien entendu que les
enfants qui meurent font de la peine
bien entendu que ce qui se passe sera un
champ de bataille c'est une guerre c'est
terrible mais de là à passer à l'acte
d'insulter de brûler de taper et bien
c'est là que le pas est franchi et je
veux le redire il est franchi que d'un
seul côté parce que je n'ai pas
d'exemple de membres de notre communauté
qui vont s'en prendre et heureusement
grâce à Dieu à des membres de la
communauté musulmane parce qu'il y a le
conflit à Gaza ça n'est je l'ai pas vu à
ce jour en tout cas pas depuis le 7 ctob
l'antisémitisme on on le voit il est
documenté euh il y a aussi la question
politique euh les responsables
politiques doivent être exemplaires en
la matière il y a un antisémitisme
ancien de d'extrême droite qu'on a pu
voir à l'œeuvre récemment dans un tweet
d'une eurodéputé RN sur Gabriel hatal
qui est é aussitôt retiré est-ce qu'il y
a un antisémitisme d'extrême gauche bah
déjà si comme les institutions
internationales le reconnaissent
l'antisionisme et de l'antisémitisme oui
euh il y a toute une frange de l'extrême
gauche de de LFI qui participe de ce
climat qui souffle sur les braises qui
non seulement défend la cause
palestinienne mais va bien au-delà en
sa'acoquinant avec des personnages comme
Corbin en Angleterre jéréy Corbin euh en
en finalement prenant le parti sans
cesse du Hamas pas seulement des
Palestiniens en ne reconnais Jean-Luc
Mélenchon par ses tweet est
antisémite est-ce que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
est antisémite je ne diraiis pas comme
ça sur ce plateau mais qu'il véhicule
des idées naséabondes qui rappellent
l'antisémitisme même parfois celui
d'avant-gerre oui je le dis alors je
vous ai lu vous êtes opposé à la
présence de Mathilde Panau la présidente
du du groupe insoumis à l'Assemblée à
l'hommage du 7 le 7 février aura un
grand hommage aux Invalides présidé par
Emmanuel Macron hommage aux otages
français il en a une quarantaine
français tué par le Hamas
elle n'a pas sa place alors je ne peux
pas m'y opposer parce que c'est un
hommage national et que le protocole
prévoit que les présidents de groupe
seront invités donc elle est présidente
du groupe LFI ou nups à l'Assemblée
national je ne peux pas le remettre en
cause mais je suis choqué pas tant par
sa demande de présence mais sa demande
d'amalgame pour que cet hommage soiti
aussi celui rendu dit-elle aux victimes
franco-palestiniennes et cet amalgame me
fait mal parce qu'il y a eu 41 français
israéliens franco-israéliens qui ont été
tués lors du massacre du des massacres
du 7 octobre et vouloir finalement
mettre la pagaille dans cette
commémoration ramener tout au centre de
du conflit de Gaza alors qu'on veut
commémorer un massacre celui du 7
octobre je trouve ça la malsin j'ai
employé des mots forts sur une station
de radio je vais pas les redire ici mais
je trouve qu'effectivement c'est
indécent c'est pas la première fois que
les membres de la France insoumis ont
des propositions indécentes on les
appelle souvent LFI la France indécente
sur les réseaux sociaux et je trouve que
c'est tout à fait justif ben voilà vous
êtes libre de votre parole et vous
l'avez montré ce soir merci Maître Ariel
Goldman d'être venu pour commenter ces
ces chiffres de de l'explosion des acten
s'est mite en France vous restez avec
moi c'est l'heure des parti prix de nos
affranchis on accueille nos chroniqueurs
tout de
suite Isabelle lasser d Figaro de la
chronique diplot bienvenue quel beau
vert éclatant ravie de vous retrouver
Thomas Lestavel pour l'économie
installez-vous on commence comme chaque
soir par Bourbon Express l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée c'est Stéphanie
Despierre qui nous la raconte ce soir
bonsoir Stéphanie bonsoir et je vous
raconte l'histoire d'une rallonge qui
fait polémique les députés vont avoir
300 € de plus pour leur frais chaque
mois leur enveloppe passe donc de 5645 €
à 5950 € par mois ce matin l'insoumis
François Ruffin sans ofusque c'est
choquant parce qu'on est dans une
assemblée on refuse l'indexation des
salaires sur inflation où on va doubler
les franchises médicales où on va
augmenter l'électricité de 10 %. bon
c'est pas normal s'il y a à se serrer la
ceinture ça doit commencer par les
dirigeant ça doit commencer par montrer
l'exemple ça doit commencer par le haut
alors dans son élan François Ruffin
annonce qu'il va donner ses C 300 € à
une association de paysans en fait il
n'a pas le droit de faire des dons avec
cet argent qui ne doit servir qu'à
rembourser les dépenses de députés même
certains de ses collègues insoumis
trouvent qu'il y va un peu fort dans
l'antiarlementarisme et lui ont demandé
de retirer ces tweets les plus les plus
virulents alors qui a décidé de cette
rallonge le bureau de l'Assemblée
nationale Myriam c'est-à-dire l'instance
qui gère le fonctionnement du Palais
Bourbon où tous les partis sont
représentés hier à l'exception des
insoumis qui se sont abstenus et de la
représentante des socialistes absente au
moment du vote tous les groupes
politiques ont voté pour cette rallonge
selon la présidente de l'Assemblée cet
argent sert à financer les frais de
permanence des députés l'essence pour
parcourir les circonscriptions ce matin
lors de ses vœux à la presse elle a dû
se justifier à plusieurs reprises et
malgré le contexte elle assume il ne
s'agit pas d'une hausse de la
rémunération des parlementaires nous
n'avons pas augmenté à nouveau le
pouvoir d'achat des parlementaires c'est
pas le sujet on est remboursé au titre
du loyer qu'on a réellement payé de la
facture de chauffage qu'on a réellement
payer ce sont des frais
professionnels alors dans cette histoire
qui fait beaucoup de polémique
aujourd'hui il y a aussi un
rétropédalage dont on parle un peu moins
un rétropédalage à grande vitesse celui
du rassemblement national hier les du
les deux vice-présidents Ren de
l'Assemblée votent pour cette rallonge
oups ce matin ils se fendent d'un commun
pour demander à yelbron Pivet un report
de la mesure et Marine Le Pen fait son m
à coupa c'est un raté il nous a paraît
inopportun même si la décision peut se
comprendre il nous a paraît inopportun
de prendre cette décision au moment où
les Français sont plongés dans une crise
de pouvoir d'achat et on apprend ce soir
que le petit groupe lot a aussi fait
marche arrière en tout cas l'utilisation
de cette rallonge sera contrôlée depuis
2017 les députés doivent pouvoir
présenter les justification de leur
frais et s'ils ne consomment pas toute
cette enveloppe ils devront rendre ce
qui reste à la fin de l'année merci
beaucoup Stéphanie des piierre maître
Goldman c'est plidable la rallonge des
frais de mandat en pleine crise de
l'inflation pour un avocat tout est
plidable mais c'est vrai que en
opportunité je sais pas si le timing été
très bien choisi mais est-ce qu'on
pouvait prévoir bon on enchaîne avec
avec vous Thomas Thomas Lestavel ce soir
vous vouliez rebondir sur une étude de
l' montaig qui est sortie hier et qui
traduit une grande angoisse chez les
classes moyennes effectivement Myriam
c'est la peur du déclassement alors de
qui parle-t-on l'Institut Montaigne nous
propose une définition qui mérite d'être
très simple les classes moyennes c'est
vous prenez la population vous enlevez
les 30 % les plus pauvres les 20 % les
plus riches et il vous reste les classes
moyennes ça fait quand même la moitié de
la population ça correspond aux
personnes qui gagnent entre 1440 et 3100
€ nets par mois on devrait le voir sur
le tableau donc en dessous c'est les
catégories modestes et adessus ce sont
les catégories aisées c'est une
population mystérieuse hein très
hétérogène elle est scruté de près par
les pouvoirs publics depuis la révolte
des gilets jaunes en 2018 tout le monde
veut la comprendre tout le monde veut la
draguer et le Premier ministre Gabriel
hatal déclare par exemple qu'elle est le
cœur battant de notre beau pays pourquoi
alors euh c'est une population
importante mais qui se sent frustré et
c'est ce que montre l'Institut
monountaine dans dans son rapport les
classes moyennes donc payent beaucoup
d'impôts de taxes et trouvent qu'ils
n'ont pas droit aux prestations sociale
équivalente qui elles sont réservées au
plus modeste alors les pouvoir les
pouvoirs publics pardon ont tenté de
corriger le tir ces dernières années il
y a eu une baisse de l'impôt sur le
revenu il y a eu la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation et plus récemment la
semaine dernière Emmanuel Macron qui
promet 2 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires de baisse d'impôt pour
les classe moyenne mais malgré tout ça
ne suffira pas ah bon pourquoi alors
pour quelle raison alors 2 milliards
d'euros si on considère que c'est la
moitié de la population déjà c'est un
peu du saupoudrage c'est pas ça qui va
vraiment changer la donne les classes
moyennes elles ont vu flamber leurs
dépenses bah comme tous les restes des
Fran comme les autres Français he en
carburant la facture d'énergie également
et le truc c'est que le SMIC qui lui est
revalorisé automatiquement avec
l'inflation en revanche la plupart des
salariés n'ont pas obtenu les
augmentations de leurs employeurs qui
leur auraient permis de compenser cette
hausse de prix donc l'échelle des
salaires se tasse et ça ça crée de la
frustration et puis le problème le plus
grave c'est celui de l'accès au logement
qui stagne depuis 15 ans et là encore on
a un tableau qui est assez révélateur on
voit que le taux d'accès à la propriété
il n'augmente plus depuis 15 20 ans et
ça c'est la faute de la hausse des taux
d'intérêt alors il y a effectivement
cette hausse des taux sur les crédits
immobiliers qui ont doublé l'an dernier
on est passé à peu près de 2 à 4 % et
puis surtout la tendance de fond c'est
la hausse des prix de l'immobilier qui
est énorme et qui fait mal entre 2013 et
2023 la valeur des logements a pris 30 %
en moyenne en France et alors l'Institut
montagne sort un chiffre qui est très
intéressant en l'an 2000 il fallait
environ 10 ans pour acheter un 100 m² en
France aujourd'hui c'est 15 ans donc la
moitié de plus et je vous parle pas des
logements à Paris qui là sont
complètement hors compétition les class
au final sont un peu le cul entre deux
chaises excusez-moi l'expression c'est
qu' elles sont à la fois trop riches
pour prétendre au logements sociaux et
trop pauvres pour présenter au banquers
un apport suffisant et les seuls
finalement qui peuvent acheter ce ceux
sont ceux qui ont un import grâce à un
héritage ou à une donation familiale
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire si les
réductions d'impôts ne suffisent pas
alors il y a deux choses qu'on peut
faire déjà il faut absolument relancer
la construction des logements neufs et
là la situation est inquiétante puisque
on est arrivé à un plus bas niveau
depuis 30 ans donc là il y a clairement
quelque choses à faire et ensuite il
faut aider ces classes moyennes à
acheter et là on est une mesure qui va
dans le bon sens le ministre de
l'Économie a élargi récemment le prêt à
taux zéro pour 6 million de França en
plus et ça c'est une bonne décision
parce que quand on peut devenir
propriétaire de son logement c'est le
meilleur remède contre la peur du
déclassement merci beaucoup Thomas
Lestavel on en parle et on va en
reparler des des classe moyenne comment
comment réussir à prendre à prendre leur
pou et à être efficace pour leur
redonner un peu de pouvoir d'achat
Isabelle ler on termine avec vous la
Russie accuse l'Ukraine d'avoir abattu
un avion transportant des prisonniers
Ukrainiens vrai ou faux alors
euh on ne sait pas encore il y a plus de
questions aujourd'hui que de certitude
la seule chose qu'on sait de manière
sûre c'est qu'un il yuchine 76 russe a
été abattu dans la région de russe de
Belgorod sur la présence de prisonniers
ukukrainien dans l'avion elle n'a pour
l'instant été étayée par aucune preuve
c'est même plutôt le contraire puisque
la chef propagandiste du kremelin
Margarita Simonian a essayé de publier
une une liste de ses prisonniers et
qu'elle était fausse puisque certains
avait déjà été euh euh libéré en fait
alors qui a pu abattre cet avion et ben
les deux parties la Russie parce qu'elle
l'a déjà faite on se souvient en 2014
qu'elle avait abattu un avion de la
Malaysian Airlines le mh17 et puis
beaucoup plus récemment au mois d'août
2023 l'avion de Prigogine après sa
rébellion contre le kemelin avait lui
aussi été abattu et puis le gouverneur
de Belgorod a aussi affirmé euh qu'il
avait que sa défense aérienne avait
abattu un drô de type avion le matin
même donc on peut penser que c'est la
piste russe les Ukrainiens c'est
possible ai les Ukrainiens aussi même
avec des Ukrainiens à bord même si c'est
pas sûr parce que il y avait
probablement pas de prisonniers
Ukrainiens à bord par contre il y avait
peut-être des armes donc on sait que la
région de Belgorod est devenue une zone
de guerre en fait puisque les Ukrainiens
bloqués sur le
front ont pris belgorode pour cible donc
il y a beaucoup de d'échanges d'armes et
puis les Ukrainiens on entré depuis
quelques semaines qui savaient abattre
des avions russes puisqu'ils ont abattu
un A50 qui est un avion radar et puis
ils sont aussi descendu cinq avions de
de chasse donc si l'avion transportait
vraiment des armes il est aussi possible
que ce soit les ukrainien qui l' est
abattu et c'est pourtant la la version
russe qui circule alors c'est la version
russe et c'est d'ailleurs un petit peu
problématique parce que dans tous les
médias européens comme une traînée de
poudre s'est répandu la version russe
des fait c'est-à-dire que un avion russe
avec 60 ou 50 prisonniers Ukrainiens
avait été abattu sans aucune
confirmation on a repris les éléments de
langage du kemelin en fait on prend pour
argent compent tout ce qui vient du
kremelin c'était aussi le cas la semaine
dernière quand le kremelin a affirmé
qu'il avait dans un bombardement tué une
cinquantaine de mercenaires français
c'était une fake news cette fake News a
été reprise sans être vérifiée par tous
les médias français c'est ça fait partie
de la guerre informationnelle russe
cette guerre va va augmenter avant les
élections européennes et avant les
élections russes le 17 mars vous vous
mettez en garde toujours questionner le
narratif russe systémaou la fin ça sert
toujours le cremmelin parce que calomnié
calomnié il en restera toujours quelque
chose quel est le but du kremelin pour
terminer alors le but du kremmelin c'est
d'abord en fait de de semer le doute
dans la population ukrainienne à un
moment où on se demande si l'union
sacrée après 2 ans de guerre n'est pas
en train de se fragiliser c'est
d'essayer en en fait de faire flancher
les Européens et essayer d'enrayer en
fait l'aide
militaire à l'Ukraine et c'est aussi en
fait un moyen de de conforter le
discours officiel du kremelin vis-à-vis
de la population russe puisque le
kremelin dit que ce n'est pas une guerre
de la Russie contre l'Ukraine mais que
c'est une guerre de l'OTAN contre la
Russie donc de l'OTAN et de son allié
ukrainien ce sont eux qui attaquent la
Russie donc à la fin ça sert la Russie
et et c'est vrai que euh il faut c'est
on est vraiment dans une guerre
informationnelle dont dont les dont les
gouvernement européens n'ont pas à mon
avis enc mesuré l'emple il est temps
hein il est temps les théâtres d'ombre
de Vladimir Poutine on arrive au 2 ans
j'imagine que vous suivez un peu on a
encore les les moyens nous les européen
de faire en sorte que l'Ukraine gagne
cette guerre d'un mot alors je suis pas
du tout géopolitique mais euh faut
espérer faut l'espérer parce que sinon
c'est vraiment un drame pour l'Europe si
l'Ukraine perd merci les affranchis on
s'arrête là merci pour vos chroniques
Stéphanie Despierre à très vite c'est la
fin de cette émission Merci à VOUS Ariel
Goldman d'être passé sur notre plateau
tout de suite votre soirée documentaire
Jean-Pierre gracien bien sûr à
[Musique]
demain